news coming out of indianapolis today if
you're a colts fan
jason lochenfora joining the show right
now cbs sports breaking news that
carson wentz is going to be out five to
12 weeks
uh jason what does this mean for the
cults moving forward
he's a lot of jacob in the short term
that's for sure
um it means the odds of them having to
send
a one back to uh philadelphia as part of
the
wench trade which is obviously
predicated on him taking at least
seventy percent of the snaps
um i i would say that seems highly
unlikely
at this point um you know for carson
wentz it's it's just more questions
about the
the the durability and and his body
where he
is at this point in his career what
he can get back to realistically i know
this is
sort of emanating from an injury that
happened maybe as far back as high
school but
but the reality is he he's had to endure
a number of procedures now in a short
period of time
and we're now talking a a a
long period of time removed from him
being at the top of his game when
he looked like he was going to be you
know one of the top six
eight ten quarterbacks in this league
for a long time
uh obviously it continues a run of bad
luck
excuse the pun for chris ballard um
since he took over as general manager
there and
and you know andrew luck's career ending
sort
sure sooner than anybody anticipated um
and now they continue to sort of play qb
roulette and it certainly could be a
precursor to a transaction at some point
i wouldn't expect anything right away
but at some point depending on how
things go through
camp and and maybe um a pre-season game
or so
you don't like to bring in a a
quarterback this late in the game but
we've seen teams do it right we saw
minnesota
make a big trade uh for sam bradford
when teddy bridgewater had a horrific
injury years ago
um and so maybe there is something out
there for the cult at
some point a lot of people will say nick
falls i don't think that's the direction
that
they probably want to go up personally
i'd be looking at a gardener mitchu
something like that
if i were gonna make a trade in terms of
age and upside
um and what you'd have to pay the guy um
but for now
they're gonna really sink in and and see
what jacob eason can do
jason lochenford joins the show cbs
sports nfl insider ben lyons in for rich
on the rich eisen show
i saw your tweet just now jason and and
your timeline feels a little different
than the one brockman and i were coming
up with
before you jumped on chris and i were
trying to do the math and we said okay
it's probably gonna come back november
1st you're talking about eight
months are we going to see him on the
football field at all this season i say
months i meant weeks if i said months it
was a
it was a mistake multitasking no i think
eight weeks to
two months eight weeks is is what we're
probably i mean
look when they say five to 12 weeks it
it's not going to be five
you know that's just not how it goes um
and especially
with he just you know yeah he was there
for the spring but i mean he
just started practicing i know he's been
with frank wright before
but he didn't even really get them to
put his base on yet before this happened
so
you know you're talking about a guy who
now has to go on the shelf for a while
it's not like uh he's gonna come back
three days after surgery
have a practice and you know play the
next week
so now i i think you're looking at eight
eight weeks two months
probably at a minimum like i i can't
imagine this doesn't bleed
um well into the regular season and and
the best case scenario
and then you're also look this is
somebody who has a big contract
um this is somebody who's dealt with a
lot of setbacks in the past
so as much as you'd like to get them
back as soon as possible
um that they're not going to be it you
know trying to do anything
warp speed because he may be a guy who
still is a part of your future
beyond this year if if if you think he's
still who you
thought he could be when you made the
trade so yeah i think conservatively
if they're saying you know five weeks to
three months
you're going to be looking at at least a
couple of months
what's crazy jason is if i'm an eagles
fan this morning
i'm so upset because of the the claws on
the the trade regarding the draft pick
he's making the eagles worse still he's
still
hurting the eagles how is that possible
stuff
stuff happens stuff happens um it's just
it's just the reality how do you being
an eagles
it i i mean i don't think you can look
at it
that way as an eagle fan i i mean i get
white
why
you might but like there's a reason that
the trade went down the way did
right it's because of everything that's
transpired with him
physically and and what he played like
last year so like the eagles can't make
that trade
banking on that one no i mean that one
has to be earned in part through
lock-in in part through productivity um
and and just through health so
it's just really remarkable that if
you're an eagles fan you're sitting
sitting here today saying wow we're
continuing to not
get better because of carson wentz but
like carson wentz needing a procedure is
that shocking to people
of course not no of course not it's part
of the reason he's he's not there
right it's it's part of the reason he
hasn't lived up to the contract it's
it's part of the reason that
outside of the cults that you know it's
not like there was this
super robust carson wentz market
availability is a skill set jason that
is often overlooked in sports and
in life how does this impact the rest of
the teams in
the division uh not just in terms of a
possible trade scenario or anything like
that but just in terms of where the
balance of power is now in the afc
i for me personally it's tennessee and
everybody else and it was that way
before
now i i thought the colts were the team
that um
because of their ability to play some
defense especially if they can get
theirs leonard
back inside long term and their ability
to run the ball and i know they lost you
know their
their left tackle there's some change
there but i still think up front
that's a formidable unit that they built
so you know they were the next best team
i i don't know what carson once was
going to do you know i don't know that
anyone could say they had built a model
that told them with absolute certainty
what a 2021 carson once was going to
look like in terms of games played and
you know yards touchdowns everything
else so i i mean i i think they were
um a bit of a wild card before
and and they still are now um
and then the other two come on you know
that's yeah jacksonville and houston
have a
ways to go so i don't know that it
necessarily swings the balance of
of power um i think certainly
they probably emphasize running the ball
and and sort of going a little more old
school
even more than than they may have
previously or or might have
underwent but i don't i don't like
i have no idea what a full carson went
season would look like it and again i
don't know that you can
bake into your cake a full carson win
season
no clearly not jason lochenford joins
the show cbs
sports nfl insider anything going on
right now jay in the world of sports
with
nba free agency and the olympics and
baseball down the
the you know the the home stretch of the
pennant race i think we kind of forgot
that there's a hall of fame game this
week
tj jefferson didn't forget this weekend
so they certainly are they haven't
forgotten there they weren't pads two
straight days
um i i was at saturday's practice
uh you know they were in heinz field i
know probably about twelve
fifteen thousand people there so it was
cool well it was a football festival and
and
uh yeah that they obviously will be the
first ones to play the cowboys both
those teams dealing with some health
issues
uh the first string pittsburgh offensive
line that i saw
saturday now
you know there was at least three
projected starters
who are dealing with middling injuries
or just getting a veterans day off but
regardless
um something out that offensive line is
clearly priority number one
for them right now no tj's hype being a
cowboys fan because that's all they have
is hype
is there any meat on the bone for the
cowboys this year because it's a lot of
hype it's like a
yeezy album we don't know when it's
going to come out if it's going to be
good
it's a lot going on usually not the
the it's like the hype man
is better than the artist themselves you
know that's and jerry's usually the hype
man and it's usually out there in oxnard
and
you know everybody's fired up and man we
look good and we're
look at this roster and you know and
then it leads
you know somewhere between seven and
nine wins um
i just don't buy the defensive side of
the ball with them still um
the situation with dak is less than
ideal
um with him having to miss anytime after
all the time he's missed
you know a lot of people are selling
zeke's back he's gonna be dominant i i
don't know i
i think they're kind of where pittsburgh
was a year ago with the offensive line
sometimes by the time
comes like for a bunch of guys at once
in a position group
and age injury it all kind of conspires
against you and i just
don't know that they're gonna get their
best five out there
with the consistency that they're gonna
need um
see i have reservations about the
cowboys well it's crazy jason when you
look at that
entire division there's not one team i
can really wrap my arms around and
celebrate and get excited for and
especially
the philadelphia eagles and news coming
out that devante smith is expected to
miss two to three weeks
with a sprained mcl brockman was
freaking out because jalen hurts was
ranked on some preseason pre-draft board
as like a top 10
fantasy quarterback let's talk real
football though
what's happening in philadelphia and
forget just losing out on the draft pick
from carson wentz
well i i mean look there they're not
ready to um
anoint jalen i i think there's a lot of
quality clay there to mold and i was
impressed
more often than not by what i saw him do
a year ago under duress
but there there are movers and shakers
there you know they're not uh
a front office in an ownership group
that tends to
sit still so yeah they'll be
they have been and they will continue to
evaluate any and every quarterback
situation that might give them
an opportunity to upgrade and there's
obviously um
significant mitigating circumstances
with the the sean watson situation
but um they they are not
ready to say we absolutely have the guy
what while they are entertaining that
idea
and wanting to to be you know would love
for that to be proven
true um but yet the division i don't
know man
i leaned to wft
because of that defense and because of
some of the
additions they've made on offense that i
think will just provide a
a baseline and because they have a lot
of guys who are young you know gibson
has been running back that long look at
thomas hasn't been planning on but for
what they've already showed small sample
size
um and without having the hacking thing
and all the stuff they were dealing with
a year ago i
i i leaned to them before the covet
situation
and now i i take a step back
because if at this point they're still
dealing what they're dealing with
having a coach who's you know a cancer
survivor potentially a moon
immuno compromised um
and and him being as sort of
out front and honest almost begging
these guys to to do the right thing
and still not enough of them have that
you know i'm not i can't look at that
and say that that portends greatness now
maybe that
those numbers will change drastically
here in the in the near future
um but i think it would be naive
to pretend that coven you know is not
going to play any role in this season
because it it already is
jason lokenford joins the show cbs
sports nfl
insider kind of look at him as a dual
threat around here like an antoine
randall
l or cordell store can do a little bit
of everything because in addition to
being an insider on
american football you have a passion for
football around the world i know you're
a big soccer guy
uh i was bummed out last night to see
the women lose in the olympics but the
men won in the gold cup what does this
win mean
the united states men's soccer program
um
i mean look long-term i i don't think
you can look at this nation's cup
and even this gold cup given where it is
on the calendar and what else was going
on and
especially for teams um that that are
participating in the olympics the men
didn't qualify
and say that it's i mean these are these
are money grabs for for
you know for concacaf and and for and
for fifa i i
i so i'm not going to go crazy about it
they're putting together results
and they're building what seems to be a
winning culture
um i have reservations about great bear
although
and some of what's going on but but they
seem to continue to come out the other
side of it with the result but this
group
taking part in in the gold cup
god willing health you know good health
would provide that come september and
world cup qualifying
the group playing those games looks
drastically different than the group
that endured the gold cup um but they're
they're getting results beating mexico
something you have to always celebrate
uh
and i just hopefully will continue to
see a pipeline of our best young talent
getting to europe as quickly as possible
because there is no substitute
for the kind of competition in practice
uh and for the match day squad that
comes
over there it's it's just not the same
here and it won't be for a long time
that's how you know jason's a real
soccer fan and student of the game
united states wins the gold cup he's
like uh i need to see more
i like it i like the tempered excitement
happy as hell like it's it's awesome
but i think you have to view some of
these tournaments and and the teams
as they're sort of presently comprised
for what it is
no i i appreciate the insight and and
like we said earlier availability is
everything and the united states soccer
team
on the men's side is gonna have a much
different roster when it competes for a
world cup we appreciate you taking some
time jay
my pleasure man have a great afternoon
thank you jason la confora cbs sports
nfl
insider hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here